Jamal when you heard this move did you
think oh this is a move that can take
the heat to the next level or I don't
get it which side I like the move
because Scary Terry brings a whole
different Swagger a whole different
confidence and he can he can people
don't know list about Jimmy Butler Jimmy
is okay being Robin on the courted times
he doesn't mind passing the ball saying
you take over for stretches Terry can do
that he can take over stretches he can
take over games he's another big shot
maker he's going to work hard he's going
to live in the gym we all know the heat
culture I think it's a perfect fit for
them does he blend in the heat culture I
mean I think he needs to understand the
culture I don't really know him
personally but it looks to me to be like
a player that does what he wants to do
when he wants to do it and I don't think
he he cachur allows that they they they
have a system uh you know they have
hierarchy so you know is he going to be
willing to just be the point guard that
they're looking for like taking all
those ill advised shots if they're not
going in spos is not going to be happy
with that he has had a very efficient
season so I do want to stand up for my
guy but um I wish him well but he he
needs to understand that the heat
culture is is is similar to papovich
culture you do it that way or you're
going to be traded again trust me I know
and the the Kyle Lowry aspect now he
moves to Charlotte but your your final
take on the trade here you know I think
Terry's going to definitely help Miami
um you have Kyle Larry on an expiring
contract um going to wherever I think he
ends up Landing in a contend Contender
uh but Terry oir I'm with Jamal I think
he can take the pressure off he's a
great catch and shoot three-point
shooter he's had to generate a lot of
offense in Charlotte so I think that
aspect of his game will be on display
with Miami I think the biggest thing is
like Charlotte doesn't play a lot of
Defense no so I think with the heat you
have to defend and um you know it's
going to be quick getting him acclimated
to the defensive system and I'll tell
you what if they have to play Boston in
the playoffs ter rier is going to be
real
confident